Good morning.
Thank you all so much for coming today.
Google.
We're delighted to welcome Patty McCord.
Patty is one of the world's foremost experts on company culture.
Uh,
she was an early employee at Netflix and she was a coauthor of the famous,
uh,
Netflix culture deck,
which a Sheryl Sandberg said was one of the most important documents to come out
of Silicon Valley.
Um,
she's here today to discuss her new book titled Powerful Building,
a culture of freedom and responsibility,
um,
which was largely,
an effort to sort of boil down,
uh,
the message of,
of the famous a note,
uh,
Netflix culture deck.
So please join me in welcoming to Google,
uh,
Miss Patty McCord.
So I'm just going to couple how many people have seen the Netflix culture deck?
A couple of you?
Um,
it,
I didn't ride it.
I didn't coauthor it with Reed Hastings,
the CEO of Netflix Reed an I did another company before Netflix,
a company called pure software.
We sold software tools to other software engineers and we grew through merger
and acquisition.
And how we grew was a,
we'd acquire a company and every time we'd acquire company we'd double.
So we were like a hundred,
200,
416 ride.
And then we sold the company to our largest competitor.
And my job was to take their employee handbook and our employee handbook and
smash them together and come up with the fewest pos,
the fewest policies that would piss off the fewest people.
And so what we decided to do at Netflix that was different was pay attention to
the kind of company that we were working at,
primarily for totally selfish reasons.
I didn't want to work with a brilliant assholes anymore and I wanted to have
permission to say no.
And uh,
read wasn't very,
very tolerant of people who weren't very smart or weren't very into the company.
So what we decided to do differently for those of you that have read the Netflix
culture deck is just write stuff down.
So my journey was not only to write down what kind of company that we wanted to
work at.
My job was to be the COO of that culture,
which meant if we said this,
then did we do this?
And that's the part where most companies get it wrong.
And I want you to go away from my talk today and think about what you're doing
here and what you're saying you are as Google and who you really are acting as
Google because that's what company culture really is.
So since I've been away,
I get to talk to people who are outside of business and who are,
um,
people who are kind of on the speaker circuit.
So I ended up on stage with a lot of coaches,
like real coaches,
like from real professional sports teams.
So I was in Montreal last year in February.
Has Anybody been to Montreal in February?
So cold,
it is so cold.
So I called up my daughter and I said,
hey,
by the way,
I'm doing this talk in Montreal in February.
She's like,
mom,
go to Patagonia.
Go now,
get a puffy coat,
get the big one.
So then I realized how Dang cold it is in Montreal in February.
So I figured out my hotel so that I can go underground so that I can go up to
the venue,
which is a place called the bell centre.
Does anybody know what happens at the Bell Center in Montreal?
You know hockey fans,
Huh?
Okay.
Well that's where the Stanley Cup is played.
Um,
now at this point I've been talking to groups who are a little bigger than you,
but not much.
Like as if this room was full as kind of my biggest audience.
So I go down below and at the last minute they said to me,
oh by the way,
you're not going to be on stage alone.
You're going to be with this guy named Scotty Bowman.
So I Google Scotty Bowman and he's a hockey coach.
He's the winning his hockey coach in history in the national hockey league.
So I made him under ground.
Right?
We're underground at this venue and he's this older gentleman,
he's like 70,
and he has on a little suit with the maple leaf pen and an American flag.
And we're talking about his grandkids.
And um,
he says to me,
we're under the ice and then it occurs to me,
we're in a hockey stadium,
like a hockey stadium,
right?
So it's not you guys,
it's not this little intimate room.
I go up on stage and my face is on the jumbo tron.
I mean,
he was like,
ah,
it's really scary and there's thousands of people in the audience.
And so they,
he introduces me nice introduction.
The audience claps very politely and I go sit on my little velvet couch and
Scott Bowman comes up and the place goes crazy.
I'm in Montreal in a hockey stadium with the winningest hockey coach in history.
They're clapping like this,
right?
If they had had those foam fingers,
they'd be doing the foam fingers.
I mean,
people are like taking selfies because I'm on stage with God as far as they're
concerned in Montreal.
So he comes up,
he sits down the master of ceremonies who has a diamond earring and you know,
teleprompter and he's doing the work in the audience and he says,
Mr.
Bowman,
you know,
you're such a legend.
You've won so many tournaments,
you've played with all the great players.
What does it take to be a winning team?
How do you give people feedback?
And he says,
uh,
well,
we have an 80 game season and every 10 games I sit down with each player and I
do an assessment of how they're doing.
They do a self assessment,
we pull all the stats,
we get feedback from the other coaches,
we get feedback from the other players.
We talk about who we're going to play in the next 10 games,
what the competition is,
where their strengths and weaknesses are.
And we put together a that we're going to execute for the next 10 the game so
that that person can be an incredibly high performer.
So the guy says to me,
Patty Mccord,
um,
you've been known for saying how much you hate the annual performance review.
Uh,
and I do.
I think it's an utter total waste of time for most companies that do it that
way.
And so he said,
if you didn't do that,
what would you do instead?
And I said,
what?
He said,
because the thing is that sports coaches know how to put together teams that
win.
And that's really all that management really is as far as I'm concerned.
For 30 years I'd been watching people put together teams and it's all about
doing that.
And the reason I also put the slide up that says team is that,
and I,
you know,
you probably don't say this much here,
but in case you do,
you're not a family,
right?
Work isn't your family,
you,
it's not undying love.
You're not going to loan your deadbeat brother-in-law money and he'll never pay
you back because you always do cause this is work and you come together to do
something that you can only do here and that's create terrific products that
make people happy.
And that joy I think of working is what really makes people happy.
And I say that here at Google where you have God's gift,
everything right?
And I know that when you go home and you say,
oh my God,
it was an amazing day at work.
Almost always when you say that truthfully from your soul,
it's because you did something hard with really smart people that made you
really effective.
And that's my observations of teams over all those years.
And then in order to make it work,
it's about putting together the right teams.
So because I started as a recruiter,
I think a lot about talent and what I want to talk to you about is you,
you today,
because I think I don't need to lecture you guys about how great organizations
should move fluidly and be more flexible and be more accepting of change because
that's the world that you live in.
But I want to talk to you about how you navigate through your own career.
So I just did a talk with 1500 HR people.
I know that's a frightening idea for most of you.
It's even a frightening idea for me.
Like when I first started talking to HR people before I wrote the book,
people walked out because I said things that really upset them.
But what I said was to 1500 HR people,
please raise your hand if you're in the job that you had when you graduated from
college.
How many people raise their hand?
Not Right?
How many of you have ever done a layoff?
1500 people raise their hands.
How many of you have ever laid off a family member?
There's always one.
Don't ask me why,
but people do that like somebody did.
And then I say,
uh,
how many of you have said the word family at work?
And 900 people raised their hands,
right?
And I say for all of you aren't in the same job.
You mean none of you could worked for a company that could handle retention,
right?
So the truth is that our lives,
our careers,
our full of lots of different jobs in lots of different organizations.
And what I love about Google these days is that you've now admitted that there's
lots of different organizations in the corporation that is Google,
all the alphabet companies.
So if you start thinking about your career and how you're going to be successful
and how you're going to move forward,
here's my hint from doing this for a very,
very long time,
is what you love to do,
that you are extraordinarily good at doing something.
The company you work for needs someone to be great at.
So if you wake up in the morning,
you don't want to come to work or you're not looking forward to,
and it seems really horrible,
then something's wrong with Patty's algorithm.
And I say algorithm because I worked with geeks all my life and I love you and I
miss you.
But if I say words like algorithm,
it helps,
right?
Okay.
So what you love to do that you're extraordinarily good at doing.
Is it important?
So when you find yourself coming to work and thinking,
they just don't care about how good I am at writing,
they didn't even realize how wonderful I am,
how talented I am.
They may realize it and not care.
That's the honest truth,
right?
And the other part is if you need somebody to be really,
really good and really,
really passionate about a problem you're trying to solve,
and they can just do it,
but they don't love it,
then you're not happy on the other side either.
So the reason why I'm telling you this is it's your job to navigate this.
It's not somebody else's job to suddenly realize that you're unhappy.
Trust me.
They know,
right?
And it's not somebody else's job to realize that you went home thinking this was
the best working day of your life.
It's yours.
So as you go through your work life,
I want you to be really cognizant of what you're learning,
what you're liking,
what you're not liking.
Half of what we learned in our careers is the work that we do that we hate,
right?
That's,
I remember driving away from a job once,
looking in the rear view mirror,
like if I never see that place again as long as I live.
And then I tried to pin it down.
What was it about that place that made me crazy?
And it was a company that had thousands and thousands of employees and they talk
the talk to them as head count.
They didn't have names,
they've,
they were just head count to be grown or shrunk or grown or shrunk.
So that's the part about talent.
Your talent is really important to wherever you work and you want to make sure
that you're in a place that recognizes that.
And then the last thing I wanted to talk to you about,
and since we're such an intimate audience,
it'd be really fun if you could talk to me.
Um,
the last thing I wanted to talk to you about is the idea of transformation.
So I spend a whole bunch of time with really big companies who invite me in to
talk about how they're going to transform into an,
you know,
an agile tech company we have here in the valley and they have no clue.
So they can't do it,
but you can.
And so the way to create the workplace that you want to have is to be vocal
about it and to speak up and for us to start talking to each other.
Really honestly about what works and what doesn't work.
And I think that you can have incredible conversations about work.
You know the story I told you about Scott Bowman at the beginning of my talk at
a couple of days,
a couple of days ago,
couple of weeks ago,
I was at this thing in Texas and the coach of the San Antonio Spurs,
it's a professional basketball team was on and it was very touchy feely audience
and the wouldn't,
somebody said,
Oh yeah,
my question for you coach is,
it must be really horrible when you have to cut people from the team after
you've put all that energy into recruiting them and having them play a whole
season and they've done their best and in doesn't that feel terrible?
And he said,
no,
actually it doesn't at all.
Like it's professional basketball.
You didn't sign up for a lifetime appointment.
Everybody understands that.
And I was in the audience thinking,
why can't we just have those conversations?
Like why?
Why can't we have those conversations with each other?
You know,
we hired you to do this thing and you were amazing.
Thank you.
We're done,
right?
You're that,
that part's over.
So now what are you going to do next?
Right?
And what I think about when I think about,
um,
Scotty's Scotty's methodology for giving people feedback.
It's called a performance improvement plan.
Too bad we ruined that word.
That,
right?
Like what if we actually got together and said,
let's put together a plan so that we can perform better?
What a concept.
But that's not what we normally do.
And so that's why I think real transformation comes from two things.
One of them is to stop speaking a language about management that no one
understands and just be able to start telling people the truth.
You know,
I just don't love you anymore.
I don't need Ya.
Or maybe the,
maybe you need something that's more interesting and stimulating over here.
Or maybe you should move on,
right?
Or maybe you're can say,
Hey,
look,
I'm,
I'm looking at a lot of other opportunities and I want to think about what that
means for me.
That you can really have those honest conversations.
And the second part is that you can,
you can tell the truth about what you want and what you need,
and your managers can tell you the truth about the future and you can navigate
your own careers through all of that and not wait for somebody else to take care
of you.
When I talk to women's groups,
I say,
look,
employee engagement does not mean somebody put a ring on it and interviewing
with another company to find out what you're worth,
which is what your worth by the way.
And if you feel like you're underpaid,
you're and you're waiting for somebody to notice,
that is not going to happen.
Go find out what you're worth.
And that happens with interviewing interviews,
get you opportunities,
interviews,
get you jobs.
You should be doing that for the rest of your life.
So when your find yourself waiting for someone in management to take care of
you,
I want you to remember my words and go take care of yourself.
Okay?
That's my talk for today.
Do you guys want to talk to me?
Let's do some Q.
And.
A.
Yeah.
Do you have them?
Do we need mics for?
Yeah,
in case we put it in the video.
The last,
the last slide is my book,
which there are some you get to have.
So if you have an organization,
particularly one like Netflix,
I've had a reputation for this where you know,
a certain number of low performers,
you're going to churn them out each year.
How do you,
how do you decide where that bars,
do you target like a certain percentage of the organization or
it wasn't like that at all.
Ever.
So here's how it typically happen.
I'll give you a story that anybody here use DVD by mail.
Okay.
Um,
so we had grown,
this is when we were transitioning to streaming when we were transitioning out
of the DVD by mail business into the streaming business.
And we had had an incredible run that particular year,
I don't remember which year it was.
We'd grown 30% quarter over quarter for three quarters in a row.
Right?
So we had our executive staff meeting and read once to go to the whiteboard and
do disaster planning because he loves it.
Like,
what if it goes to shit in a hand basket,
that's his favorite thing to do.
So I say,
Hey for sport,
what if it kept up?
What if we kept growing quarter over quarter,
30%,
quarter over quarter compounded for the next three quarters.
CFO goes to the white board,
he's doing top line revenue and he's doing that happy dance,
you know like Oh look at that
mommy,
Ted Sarandos who's our head of contents as at the time we said wistfully some
day will be as big as HBO.
Right?
And he says,
Shit you guys,
that's next year.
Right?
It's possible that will be as big as HBO next year.
And we all just looked at each other and Neil,
who was our head of product at the time said that's a third of the u s internet
bandwidth.
Right?
So,
and I'm looking at him like,
so afterwards he and I are sitting there,
I'm like does anybody know how to do that right?
Cause files,
video files were so big,
you guys remember you were around that time,
right?
And like,
how do we do,
like we had a data center cause we ship DVDs by mail.
So we're brainstorming like Google is Google is it?
Yahoo was at Ebay,
who's moving that much data that has and has gotta be in the cloud clearly.
And we're not gonna do this in a data center.
So we sit down with our it guys and they're brilliant.
The these are brilliant,
wonderful,
amazing people.
And we say,
here's the problem set.
And they say,
no worries,
you guys go exec something,
we'll build the cloud.
And I looked at them and said,
you know what,
if anybody on earth could do this,
it's you not nine months,
right?
We couldn't,
we couldn't do that.
It was just the timeframe was too short for these people to be those experts to
be able to accomplish the business objective.
And we're certainly not going to miss our window if it's there because we don't
have the right it team.
So I said to them,
that's not going to happen.
Right?
So,
but we got nine months to figure it out.
And so we turned that year,
97% of that team,
right.
Because,
and they,
most of them went on to a company called Chegg,
which is a Netflix for textbooks.
So they went and they took their physical shipping and receiving database skills
to do that.
So that was typically what happened.
Right.
Typically what happened was we'd either build something and it'd be done.
And when I used to interview Google people,
you know,
people who had an offer with you guys and an offer with us,
I would say,
look to different problem sets.
Right.
Organizing the world's information is a big problem.
Said we're delivering movies and TV shows to people's homes,
right.
Or their devices.
That's it.
One problem.
That's all we do.
So that's typically what happens.
So the DVD by mail business is still exists.
I don't know if you guys know that.
I still use it on my boat.
Yeah.
And it has a great catalog because it has everything known to humankind because
you don't have to buy rights for it.
Um,
but that business is probably,
I bet there's not a hundred people in that business anymore.
So that's more what happens.
I know reputationally what Netflix has a reputation for,
but we never said why would we do that if we said in chapter two,
we're a high performance culture.
You don't have to cut the bottom third performers because you don't have them.
And my experience is this.
If you hire somebody who can't do the job,
they're completely without fault.
That's in the interview process,
right?
That person,
that candidate has no,
there is nothing they did wrong.
You hired the wrong person.
If you hire somebody and they're close but no cigar,
right?
You know it's like,
ah,
I love you,
I love you man.
I love Ya.
Not really sure you can still do that,
but you should be honest.
Should be able to say to you,
you know what?
You're not exactly the skillset we were looking for,
but we love Ya and we're willing to take the chance if you are.
And then if it doesn't work out,
then it doesn't work out.
Right.
Everybody tried.
So that's what I'm saying.
You can start being honest in an interview.
So that's more typically what happens.
My experiences,
you either join a company that you think you're intellectually going to like and
you don't,
when you really get there.
Netflix was not a particularly good place for people who liked structure.
Yeah.
Or,
or,
or liked.
I'm just r and d work because it was so about deliverables.
Thanks.
Sure.
Yeah.
Right in front of you.
Hi.
Um,
I was wondering,
you have the idea for this generous severance package and the idea that you let
golf people easily,
uh,
did you have to change the company culture to get to the point where that became
acceptable or was that
yeah,
it took a,
if you go back and read the Netflix culture deck,
we wrote chapter each chapter after the chapter before it.
So when we said,
um,
we're going to have a high performance culture of adults,
uh,
and then we're going to give them a lot of freedom.
Uh,
it probably took four years for me to figure out how to do that.
So I had to figure out the severance package.
So let's,
let's say that in a typical company,
let's say we've hired you to do something.
You've been here four years,
you're amazing.
You've done the DVD by mail guys.
Right?
Don't need you anymore.
Now I'm going to put you on a performance improvement plan for three months to
prove you're incompetent.
But we both know you're not.
Well,
that's just mean,
right?
So instead I would say,
you know what,
we've been talking about this.
Can't wait to see where you go next.
I mean,
half of my Netflix alumni are here,
so I can't wait to see where you go next.
Um,
here's three months pay.
Let's just not go through this crazy stuff.
That's just no reason to do that.
So that's how I thought about that.
The severance packages was if I did the thing that people normally do and
instead just said,
how much is that worth?
Then I just pay you that.
Um,
I also had to have an incredible recruiting team that would hire the people for
the jobs that we needed getting done in the future.
So that took me a long time to have a really,
really top notch recruiting team.
I had to think about competitive offers.
Um,
I had to think about head count dollars in terms of dollars,
not in terms of number of people.
So in most companies,
I don't know how it works here,
but there's three ways you get a requisition approved if you want to hire
somebody.
In most companies the job,
you write a job description and either describes the person who left that you
wish hadn't a fantasy person that doesn't exist or whatever it takes to get it
approved.
None of those have anything to do with actually hiring somebody to solve the
problem.
And the truth is that when you find somebody who's really qualified to solve the
problem,
you should pay whatever it takes to get them right.
But in some co,
you know,
in some organizations,
especially when I'm with startups,
when they get to step functional scale,
I say that new team is not this team.
You're not going to make them into that particularly on problems with the
complexity.
And so that's how I,
that's how I thought about it.
I thought about it in terms of the whole thing.
You know,
how do we have not just high performers but high performers in each job to solve
each problem?
That's the difference.
Do you have any kind of personnel development in and that kind of world?
Yeah,
but not so formally ma.
My experience is the best way to develop is to be around amazing people who you
learn from all the time.
So I did a lot of mapping,
matching with people,
putting people with other people that they could learn a lot from and making a,
we had a lot of systems in place to share mostly business information.
So a lot of our,
um,
communication and education and the company was around the business,
not necessarily around those skills.
I think you learn best when you can see it,
right?
When you see somebody behaving like a great manager,
then you have a great role model.
Patty.
Um,
compensation teams love the annual performance review because it makes annual
increases equity modeling,
super simple,
perhaps even algorithmic.
Yup.
When you throw that out in favor of lots of feedback and conversations,
how do you connect the dots?
I don't have any problem with an annual compensation review.
I think it's really smart actually.
I recommend that you do them quarterly and walk through the company quarterly.
Um,
the most important way to think about compensation is market based pay.
So,
and the most real,
uh,
compensation information in your companies,
in your recruitment team,
not in the last year survey.
That's what is really happening.
You want to know what's really happening.
That's my problem with,
with most standard compensation teams is they operate on systems and with data
that's really old.
So,
and I don't know if you guys do,
I know that you guys are more analytic than that,
but so I would usually walk through the organization and say,
where have I hired a lot of people?
Um,
because where I've hired a lot of people that's going to give me really current
salary information that's going to color how I pay the people that are currently
there that you want to stay,
right?
So I don't have any problems at all with it.
The problems I have are when we take the review and the compensation and the
feedback and we throw them all together once a year and we say it solves those
problems.
So I was going to tell you earlier,
the most innovative work I did at Netflix was not anything new.
It was just I stopped doing old things that don't matter anymore.
So the story I told you about Scotty Bowman is his story about giving great
feedback and if you're going to give people great feedback that's going to
affect their performance,
you're not going to do it once a year,
a name,
one of the thing you do once a year that you're good at,
that would be nothing.
Right?
So great feedback.
So if you want to create a system that says,
I believe that feedback improve performance,
I want to create a system that does that,
then who would ever come up with the annual performance review?
It's a dumb system to do that.
If you say,
I want to have an annual compensation review where I do a point in time,
look across the organization and see his pay working out fairly and equitably
for people and is it market based,
right?
Am I paying competitively then that's a completely reasonable exercise to do.
There's where I have the problem is we mush it together and we're not clear.
The other thing,
the other problem I have with a lot of compensation systems is they're not
transparent to employees.
It's magic that happens in HR,
right?
And even some HR people don't know how it works,
The recruiting team doesn't know how the comp team works is this crazy stuff.
So again,
it's about like,
um,
I got rid of the,
uh,
when I was at Netflix,
I got rid of paid time off,
uh,
keeping track of paid time off.
I got rid of a travel policies and I got,
I actually,
I didn't get rid of these things.
I,
I vetoed them before we installed them.
Uh,
the travel policy and,
and getting approvals from finance for expenditures.
It seemed insane to me that I would say any expenditure over $5,000 has to be a
pro.
$10,000 has to be approved by finance.
And I got a company full of PhDs in math like a mine.
You know,
they know that 10,001 is more than 10,000 and you don't need somebody in finance
to tell him that.
But they might need somebody in finance to sit with them as an analyst.
Right.
And tell them what things are happening and how they're trending.
Is this the hook?
Are you coming to hook me?
Oh cause you look at your little c,
that's a Google problem.
I told you I'd say that.
Does that make sense to you?
Yet to have any problem with the system.
It's just needs to be transparent and it needs to be.
And because your current pain top of market,
the feedback is kind of irrelevant.
No,
they're two different things there.
Two,
they're two different things.
See is their pay for performance and Netflix are not really,
there's high performance.
Okay.
So you're going to be paid top dollar for doing a fabulous job with amazing
people on time with quality.
Okay,
so we're going to just pay there.
We're not going to pay like what you did an okay job.
So I'm going to give you an okay raise if you did an okay job,
we're going to talk about weather where you're at and whether or not you still
need to be there.
Right?
And then how I determine what pay is his market,
what do you were somewhere else.
I listened to his true story.
I would say to my vice presidents,
go interview at Google.
They're like,
no one knew.
What are you talking about?
I'm love it here.
I'm like,
no,
no God's.
And they're like shit.
And Google,
it takes like seven weeks and five.
I'm like,
I want to know what they're paying VBS.
This is good to go.
Go ahead of you.
I would tell my my employees,
look when the recruiter calls before you say no thanks,
be sure you say how much and come down on me.
Cause that's,
that's real comp data.
Real comp data is what was,
somebody else will pay you.
So it's not just paying people a lot and it's not just paying people for
performance.
It's almost the opposite.
It's expecting extraordinary performance and paying you well for the
extraordinary work.
And then the other thing is not all jobs are equal and not all jobs are equally
as important to the company.
So I'm doing,
I do also,
so I tend to talk to like big companies now and lots of startups.
So startup CEO Dinner,
I'm up in the city and one guy says,
well,
you know your high performance thing,
you don't really mean everybody.
And I said,
yeah,
I do.
I mean everybody,
you should have a high performer in every job.
And he goes,
yeah,
but not the ones that aren't important.
And I said,
well,
really,
which job at your company is not important?
He goes,
well,
you know,
like,
like payroll or something.
I said,
seriously,
you know,
when somebody really good figuring out how to pay your really brilliant
engineers,
who I'm sure are the ones that are really important.
And he goes,
well,
I'm just saying,
I'm like,
you don't want them to be accurate.
He's like,
well,
it's just,
they don't have to be like,
yes they do.
They have to be really great.
And they said,
hey,
by the way,
tip for you.
Your finance organization hates you.
And he goes,
I don't think you know my finance organization.
I'm like,
Oh hell yeah I do.
You just told me a perfect stranger.
You think your payroll supervisor is stupid.
They know you think they're all stupid cause they can't write code.
Right.
It's a completely different skill set and the egg.
And furthermore,
when you're not looking,
they're thinking of ways to torture you
because that's what finance people do.
So yeah,
I don't,
the pay for performance thing works.
When you're,
you know,
you,
what you do is valuable,
then you should pay a lot for it.
Do you want to yell or hit cons faster?
So how do you build a culture of excellence like that without also creating a
culture of fear and ego and toxicity if like,
you know,
like,
well,
fear is a hard one to get rid of because part of it is adrenaline.
So I remember one time one of our executives was talking,
one of them was,
he was talking about that this particular year,
the things that we're going to do and succeed at,
we're not going to be incremental.
They were going to be monumental.
And he used climbing k two as this metaphor,
right?
Here we are.
And so at the end,
um,
this had been a big culture of fear was the new meme around the company where at
this executive meeting.
And um,
it was a bigger meeting,
quarterly business review,
and at the end read and I get,
go to the front,
we're answering questions and he says,
oh,
I want to hear you.
And Patty talked about the culture of fear.
I'm like,
oh,
for God's sake,
really?
So read says,
well,
you know,
you just use the metaphor of k two,
you have to have oxygen,
you know,
and if you get,
if you get halfway up and a blizzard comes in,
you go back down to base camp,
there's no shame.
This is,
you know,
this isn't for the timid.
So you know,
the toxicity and the ego's,
those people just don't need to work there anymore.
Right.
Somebody,
Scott just ferret that out,
right?
And you have to,
that's why,
that's why the culture of honesty is so important so that I can say to you,
Hey,
wait a minute,
um,
excuse me,
but in this meeting she's still talking and you just cut her off.
Okay,
so,
so can you let her finish.
Thanks.
And then you do,
and she lives in,
life goes on.
You have to model the right behavior.
You have to be able to say,
that was a jerk.
Move right there buddy.
And I mean,
you just have to be able to have those conversations.
It's the schist spring that gets us in trouble.
You know,
talking shit in a whisper s that's toxic.
Right?
And if,
and you can be in my book,
there's a chapter about debate.
We loved debate,
uh,
on behalf of the customer,
on behalf of the customer.
And you can be pretty worked up when you're talking about the product.
I used to tell my HR team,
we are a service organization.
It is not spelleds e R v,
a n t,
s
and the people that we serve don't work here,
right?
The people that we serve,
our moms and our neighbors and ourselves.
So it's our job to put together teams that build incredible stuff.
You know,
when I talked to my name,
I've been gone six years.
So it's a long time and Netflix is a very different company now.
Netflix is a global original content company and what's very successful for them
now as they've extended that culture of freedom and responsibility to the
creative talent,
that's why they get the people they get right?
That's why Shonda Rhimes wants to work at Netflix and not at ABC because
nobody's walking around and telling her what to do.
It was a hand over the mic.
And then second,
just just think like how do that,
does it,
does it create a culture of like competition?
Yeah.
No,
because remember how I started with team,
right?
So the thing about the individual competing individuals,
that shouldn't happen when you have a larger collective thing to do,
right?
I mean it might happen for you guys because you have more products,
but you know,
these teams teams are,
are formed to focus on solving a particular problem in a particular timeframe.
And,
and teams are formed to do that because individuals can't
or they can't.
That's the deal.
That's the,
I tell you know,
back when I talked to startup guys again,
I'm like,
okay,
in your little startup,
here's the first sign of trouble.
Nostalgia.
Remember how it used to be,
right?
And I tell them like,
really successful companies are not made of 50 people working 24 seven it's not
about product.
It's solving goes to groups that are solving probably functional.
That's right.
Group solving problems that are clear to everybody.
So everybody has a role.
So when people are competing thin,
what is,
what are they competing for?
Is it one meaty job and you've got two people.
That's what drives competition.
Is it that,
um,
you know that in the end there's only one job and there's four people trying to
get it instead of just picking one?
I,
it's,
it goes back to honesty I think.
All right.
We'll do two more questions over there I think and then over here.
Okay.
Awesome.
Um,
thank you very much.
How she read the book.
Oh,
this amazing book.
Thank you very much for the book.
Um,
one big impression I actually got from the book is a one of a major components
for nefarious.
You sustain such a culture.
Our motto is to have a very powerful and strong recruiting team.
Yes.
And the HR department was,
um,
my question is,
I guess for a smaller company,
maybe a star up or even Netflix in his early days,
where are they recruiting worthy recruiting or HR is not as strong as it is
right now.
Yeah.
Um,
is such a,
is social culture of sustainable?
Well since you read the book,
you know that the,
the other secret of the great recruiting team at Netflix is that it's not the
great recruiting's team's job to recruit people.
It's everybody's.
And,
and the number one job of a hiring manager is to know the right talent to build
an amazing team that gets quality work done on time.
Okay.
And so I used to say,
I'll tell you this one last story.
Uh,
back in the day when I was a software engineering recruiter,
I studied the habits of software engineers.
And so I happened to know that there's always that weird ethnic restaurant in a
strip mall that is the place does your,
that you eat,
this is before we all had restaurants all over our campuses,
right?
So I'd go find that little Thai place in Cupertino and,
and you know,
and the,
on the,
in the lobby,
they'd have like the Fishbowl,
you put your business card in,
you get a free lunch.
Do you guys still go to those funky little strip mall joints?
And I go and I just take the fishbowl and I go to the back and dump it out.
And this isn't in the old days before cell phones,
right?
And I just dump it out,
write down all the names and go back to work and call them all because it was
where all the software engineers work.
And now I say that's why God gave us linkedin now.
So you can do that.
You should be looking for members of your team all the time.
It's everybody's job.
It's Hr job to facilitate it and to really understand what the market is and
where to go get people.
But it's everybody's job to bring great,
talented,
and that's the difference.
It's not just a great recruiting team and migrate recruiting team was and is so
great there because they feel like they're partners in bringing in talent.
They're not recruiters in HR.
Do you have question?
Hi Betty.
My question is how do you evaluate or think of high performance in the context
of very ambitious and risky projects that didn't go well?
Well,
I think you figure out what you wanted to,
you know,
you do it like any other software product,
I've any other product,
you postmortem it right when it didn't go well,
you stop and say,
you know,
you,
you pause and you get the team together and say,
what should we have done differently?
Right?
Did we miss scope it?
Did we miss the,
uh,
did we miss the readiness of the product for the customer?
Did we put,
was it the wrong team where we unclear about goals?
So I mean,
everything I learned about people I learned from product managers,
right?
You start with the end and you work your way back,
What are we trying to accomplish?
What's it going to look like?
What's quality look like?
When's the delivery date?
That's the other thing we don't do very well is put time rappers on stuff.
So it's like,
so yeah,
we accomplish it,
but it was six months late.
What w what should we have known when we made that date at the beginning that we
didn't know now?
So that's the part about,
you talked about development.
That's the continuous learning part that I think all of us should do as teams.
Makes Sense.
Okay.
All right.
Well thank you,
Patty.
Thank you everyone.
How many?
Let's give them already.